[Music]
California Ritz Carlton sued by guests
for serving semen contaminated water no
way someone called down to the front
desk for bottled water and a male
employee showed up to the room with five
bottles and this guy had [__] in the
bottles is that what happened a little
while later way the cookie
crumbled couple had no reason to believe
the bottles were tampered with and
defiled when they were dropped off like
honey you don't think there's Comming in
did you did you get milk this is looking
pretty milky but how could you okay yeah
let's get more details cuz [__] is like a
c's got a look yeah but if you C in a
bottle of water it gets pretty diffuse
yeah what what would it look like I
wouldn't it just look like a loose
booger in there just kind of it probably
would gross oh grow up Brian grow up
Brian you can't visualize come in water
without throwing on all right here we go
grow up bringing weak stomachs on this
show man in the lawsuit Jane claimed to
know something was wrong with the water
and she iMed immediately contacted hotel
security and
management she claimed that well how did
she know CU it has a taste tasted it
that makes sense or was it the
consistency you think I think it was The
Taste the taste yeah I think it was that
she was loving it and she was like
why do I like this more than regular
water first suspect the water was
chemically contaminated before
suspecting the water that's so true and
then I
realized this isn't a chemical flavor
this has come it's chiz it's 100% and
that's when I
knew and that's when I knew in the
lawsuit the Doe's claim one of the
hotel's employees ejaculated his seen
into a Ritz Carlton labeled water bottle
delivered it to to Jane and John Doe no
and Jane D then drank the seen
contaminated water before she realized
it had been defiled by a criminal
deviant and that she had been sexually
assaulted wow that's
crazy wait a claim adjuster confirmed
with the couple that the water was
defiled with seamen huh so they how did
they how did they know
that claim a just for tast yeah yeah oh
no this is definitely yeah that's [__]
brother yeah yeah we got a [__]
case just wishing we got another bottle
of [__] in it Alina always puts forward
the claim that coconut water tastes like
SEMA yeah uh J it doesn't totally not
yeah I've the water I really do it's
incredible you like harmless Harvest
what harmless Harvest uh thatand I think
that's the one that I it's kind of pink
it's pink yeah yeah that's good that's
good I was hurting during the marathon
and some random dude was carrying a cold
can of Co coconut water just holding it
out and I was like can I have that he's
like yeah on the sidelines yeah [__]
took that [__] they're offering you
stuff all through it right who yeah yeah
yeah like they have a station set up
full steak dinner but there's a lot of
people that just like hold [__] up yeah
Fried Chicken booths yeah exactly
10piece KFC buckets crab legs running
with a bucket crab legs yeah chicken
wings
yeah the bab how you doing surf and turf
is crazy man oh man I want to go to Red
Light are so bad soon I need a good hit
of a real chain restaurant I've been
gluten free for the past couple months
chili recently oh my slapping oh my god
really these places are so good yeah
they got they've isolated exactly what
you want to be tasting yep yep and
they're selling it to you I had Wood
Ranch Barbecue last night oh yum that
place is slapping what you have ribs
it's I did have ribs oh and Kelsey had
chicken it's just never not good and it
always tastes exactly the same that's
what you want besty is key it's amazing
what is this world's most luxurious
urinal if this is some kind of dubstep
remix under what the hell wait what is
this oh wait what oh
bro oh I could use that like for when
you're driving you know what's [__]
though is Amazon like delivery drivers
this would be ace for them because they
get they're just not allowed like their
jobs are set up that yeah if they have
packages to deliver yeah so are you guys
into uh do you guys have bedet no I need
to get one that's great I do
like go back yeah I know I want to get a
nice ass like Japanese toilet that yeah
yeah that just does the whole thing you
when you walk in yeah yeah yeah and
warms the seat I know those are crazy I
want to get one of those warm se you
guys ever see those talks of like we'll
get one someone I think maybe it's Japan
they're like they it's like people like
getting home and like putting on their
little slippers oh no like those Chinese
ads where they have all that crazy
technology and then like a little soap
dispenser and I put my dishes in this
thing that cleans them and yeah yeah
marketing the uh you know one by one
apartment living everything is just like
in a little like sad you're like this is
what this person comes home and does
after work scary I know it's like that
quote um I just read that quote again
recently that's like and when no one is
there when you go to sleep and no one is
there when you wake up in the morning do
you call it loneliness or freedom you
guys ever that
o damn call I think it says do you call
it Freedom or loneliness because it's
like you think it's freedom but actually
you're lonely yeah knock off reading I'm
free to be
alone I don't want I don't want to hang
out with anybody
anyway piss bottle I I need that for
when I sleep so I can just slam the
biggest thing of water before bed I
think that's the only scenario where you
like don't bath it sucks every day yeah
so maybe that's what it is you just
leave a couple gooses on your bedside
table Yeah you accidentally drink one
you drink
the like you're like that's the goose
and then you're like and that's a bottle
with [__] yeah know you're like that's my
[__]
Goose yeah getting all confused yeah I
got one for piss and one for wet dreams
but you forget to you forget to Mark
like Mark which one's which yeah yeah so
then someone mixes them around you're
like oh when I wake up in the middle of
the night I have to come
I don't want to go to I wake up in the
middle of the night and I just have to
come oh I really got to come right now
there there are people I maybe you guys
are like this but there are dudes I know
who are always like yeah I always jack
off in the morning and I'm like the
morning before you start your day aren
going you talked about that okay no no
no we didn't but we agree that's
straight psycho Behavior yeah morning
jerk no way I mean it's like every once
in a while maybe but it's like I'm going
to be tired after yeah no you're the
opposite of energizing yeah I was I was
saying that that's like a I I would
argue that's a young dude thing to do
all right they're like I've got so much
energy yeah yeah at 22 they like I
[__] yeah yeah go at it good morning
like you should be jacking off at night
he's like I'm going to do that too yeah
think I'm not three times a day sort of
thing yo it's your
split I do 7:00 a.m. 6:00 p.m. what are
you talking about when do you come uh
making Amazon drivers piss a number one
bestseller what the [__] is this now
what is this bottled drivers piss the
number one drink on Amazon how did I
know he was English outside of Amazon
Fulfillment centers all over the world
there always bottles of urine so what I
decided to do is collect as much of that
up as possible and turn it into a
product that I was going to sell on
Amazon specifically an energy drink
called release energy it
looks what do is list that on Amazon I
tricked its algorithm and and now I was
able to sell piss on Amazon I got as
many of my mates as possible to buy the
drink in as short amount of time as
possible and after I don't
know 5 hours real people tried to start
buying the drink and then it became a
number one drink on Amazon it's almost
funny but it's still was almost fun it's
like you're like wow a lot of people
that do like [__] like this where it's
like a higher concept video but they
don't quite piss like this what yeah
yeah you're right you're like no but
like he should have just listed it as
Amazon driver piss why did he ree it as
an energy drink because real people
buying it is not funny then because
they're just getting tricked nobody
knows it's pit that is so true when
somebody's making a comedy video and
you're like you mean you just lied to
people and they did what they would
normally do based on you lying
to
yeah